- My name is Kelly Kramarik,
I am 25 years old, and I'm
a freelance audio engineer.
Some people just stay in one trade,
one part of audio.
I like to do a little bit of everything,
so I work in a studio as a recording
and mixing engineer.
I work in live sound as a monitor
and front-of-house engineer.
In film, I'm a production sound mixer,
so my main goal is to
get the dialogue on set.
Then, in post-production,
that's when we focus on sound effects,
creating them, taking them from a library,
fully recording that, footsteps,
basically re-creating the world
that we already recorded
in a studio setting
so we have more control over it.
So, I went to school for business
and I was a vocal minor.
I had to take an elective
for my vocal classes
and it was called Music Technology,
and it was all about, you know,
microphones and speakers, and music,
and I was like, "What?",
like, "This is something I can do?"
I just, I don't know why my whole life,
in music, I had no idea that
audio engineering was a thing.
Once I took that Music Technology class,
I changed my major to
multidisciplinary studies,
which is when three
minors make up your major.
We didn't have a music tech major program,
so that's how I kinda finagled it,
and then I studied
theater and advertising.
So, the theater side of things,
I did theater sound design,
which audio engineering
in theater is huge,
so that's a whole nother avenue
that you can study.
And then, advertising because
I knew I was probably gonna
have to be a freelance person,
and so, I wanted to be
able to market myself.
I graduated from West Virginia
with my bachelor of science
and multidisciplinary
studies three years ago,
and then I immediately
moved out to Denver.
I didn't have a job lined up.
I knew there were studios in Denver.
I contacted a bunch of them
and no one wanted anything to do with me,
so for about two years out here,
for the first year, I
did nothing but bartend.
So, I was a bartender all through college
and I was bartending out here as well,
and then I found the master's program,
and I was like, "You know what?
"If no one wants to hire me right now,
"maybe I need to hone
in some more skills."
And so, I decided to
apply for graduate school.
You don't need to go to school,
but it definitely gives you a leg up
on the competition, depending
on their experience,
obviously, so once I started interning,
I was interning at this studio
in this past summer.
And the way that I got
that was just networking,
those engineer meetup groups
where I go to every studio,
I always talk to the owners.
We had a meetup at this studio
and I came to it, and I
was talking to my boss
and he said to call him.
And so, I called him and
I sent him my resume,
and he hired me as an intern.
So, I interned here for
a while over the summer,
and then at the end of the summer,
he hired me on as a
freelance audio engineer.
Randomly, I got a call
from a producer in L.A.,
I got a call from a producer in New York,
all asking me if I can do production audio
for their gigs, and I
was like, "Yeah, like,
"that's awesome," and I'm wondering how
they got my name, and I find out it's just
from one connection
where I did a good job,
and so, they give my name out to people.
One other way, I guess, that
I've been getting jobs is,
production houses in Denver don't
have audio people on
staff, and I noticed that
when I was researching
different production houses
on their websites, they
didn't have audio people.
So, I just started sending
them emails with my rates,
"If you ever need an audio
person, let me know,"
and I've gotten a couple of calls
from people that way, as well.
So, just being super proactive
and saying yes to everything
is how I've gotten where I am right now.